I haven't heard that salt makes coffee  less bitter I have heard that salt makes  everything better I have heard that salt  makes coffee less bitter but I've not  actually tried it no I've never heard  that how much salt you have to put in I  was like a blind test oh I see okay  very smooth a little nutty it's pretty  bitter but not like that bitter it's  definitely like tolerable as a cup of  black coffee I think this one does have  salt in it because that's not very  bitter as this one salt in it just  tastes worse for me okay I dig it back  that one definitely has salt in it yeah  it definitely tastes like slightly less  bitter it makes it less bitter but it  also makes it like salty salt I think  you failed the salt a quirks I like my  coffee black  like rich just ferocious I like my  coffee to punch me in the dick in the  morning since they have